>>Teacher: Do you know
where Chicago is?
>>All: Yes.
>>Teacher: Yes, oh
wonderful, where is Chicago?
>>Narrator: In the past few
years, hundreds of educators
from around the country, like this
group of teachers from Chicago,
have made the pilgrimage to
Union City in New Jersey,
a predominantly Hispanic
blue collar neighborhood,
just across the river from Manhattan.
>>Teacher: See, she's got a folder
on the server and she would save it.
These are all the projects
that she's done.
>>Narrator: Visitors come
here to check out elementary
and high school classes, to
talk with students and teachers.
>>Teacher: Do you have
sound effects on yours?
>>Student: Yes.
>>Teacher: Can I see?
>>Narrator: They experience
first hand this minor miracle
of public education, a school system
that was on the brink of being taken
over by the state, and is now one
of New Jersey's top
performing districts.
>>Fred: The reason we got in
trouble in nineteen eighty-nine was
because we had some of the
lowest test scores in the state.
They began to improve
almost immediately
with the changes that took place.
Right now, among New Jersey's cities,
we have the highest test scores.
>>Narrator: The changes that drove
the district's stunning turnaround
included a focus on early literacy.
>>Student: This story's
about a girl named Jenny--
>>Narrator: A shift away from
drills to project based learning.
>>Teacher: Or you can feed it out--
>>Narrator: And the
infusion of technology
in every facet of the curriculum.
>>Computer: Buzz, buzz, said the fly.
>>Narrator: These initiatives grew
out of the faculty's core belief
that all education should
center on the child.
>>Man: The initial plan called
for beginning with kindergarten
and first grade teachers, with a
recognition that they already were,
by nature, child-centered
because of the age
of the children they
were working with.
>>Lorraine: We want to
do all upper case, okay.
>>It's more student centered,
as opposed to teacher centered,
so the children are pretty
much running the show.
We serve as facilitators,
and help them and get them
through whatever questions they have.
They are also taught
to work with each other
and technology is wonderful
also, 'cause we incorporate
that into the curriculum.
The children know so much.
>>Computer: Frog's eyes grew
big, "Mmm, lunch," said Frog.
>>Narrator: Like other districts,
Union City has budget constraints.
At Hudson Elementary, cafeteria
workers share a basement space
with the reading lab cluster.
But the district has received
some significant technology grants
and they've learned to
maximize their resources.
>>Fred: None of this happens without
money, but a lot of that can be
and should be a restructuring
of how money is expended.
Sometimes you actually
can do more with less.
We expend very little
money on textbooks.
We spend a lot of money on children's
literature and resource materials.
>>Teacher: Cecilia, continue reading.
>>Narrator: Starting the techno
revolution in the early grades
by spending money on
computers instead of textbooks,
the district moved toward a project
based curriculum, with research done
on the web, and in the process,
it created a committed band
of change agents, a crop
of students who thought
about education in a new way.
>>Fred: The first students coming
up didn't remember the old way.
So when they came into
the high school en masse,
that was very helpful, because when
teachers would try to return them
to roles and the old fashioned way,
the kids just didn't understand,
and were extremely uncomfortable,
and began to say, "Well,
we've always had more independence,
we've done it differently.
We've been able to do
internet research,"
and they became a force for change.
>>Ela: How did you do this
effect around the photographs?
>>Andrea: I feathered five percent.
>>If you have to research something,
instead of spending numerous hours
in the library and going
through encyclopedias,
you can just research something
online, and it's more interactive.
All of our classes use technology,
no matter whether it's
science, gym, math.
We all use technology
somehow, it's all incorporated,
and it helps us learn,
'cause it makes it easier.
>>Ela: Did you try testing
this in IE to see how it looks?
>>Narrator: Even though
they had participated
in designing the new
web based curriculum,
many teachers were surprised by
the impact of wired classrooms.
>>Marjorie: I was a very
traditional teacher.
I stood up in the front
of my room, at my lectern.
I had my prepared notes.
I knew what I wanted them to
have, and I gave it to them.
The internet just broke down
the walls of my classroom.
We could go anywhere, we
could look up anything.
It was no longer a, "That's a
good question, I'll come back
with the answer tomorrow."
Well, why tomorrow?
We'll get the answer right now.
>>Ela: What you're
creating is a movie.
>>Student: Right.
>>Ela: But you could also
create it in a QuickTime format.
>>When I first began, I used the
old method of blackboard and chalk,
which I'm allergic to anyway,
and as the years evolved,
we moved more into technology
and really facilitate not only my
teaching, but my record keeping
and contacting parents and keeping
abreast with the students' work,
and more online and more on
task, and more interactivity
between the students, the
home and me, the teacher.
>>Student: I need a
flat head, small one.
>>Narrator: At Emerson High School,
the student tech team teaches
teachers how to use software,
and repairs the school's hardware.
>>Student: That's in, and I
just put the keyboard back.
>>Narrator: Another group of students
is building websites to be used
by teachers in presenting
various class subjects.
>>Student: We're each working
on like individual websites
that will tie with other classes.
We're doing it with our
history class and I'm doing it,
my website's over there,
on the Industrial Revolution,
and he's doing it on--
>>Another world.
>>Discovery of the New World.
>>Narrator: While another
group is working
on a national project exploring
technologies of the future.
>>Ela: They're researching, how
would internet two be utilized?
How would virtual reality
be utilized?
And so his graphic is all original.
It's tremendous skills.
As a matter of fact, this is his free
time, and he chooses to come here,
instead of eating or
doing something else.
>>Narrator: A program
that provided laptops
for seventh graders had a profound
impact not only on students,
but on their families as well.
Ana Calles still remembers the
day her son brought the first
computer home.
>>Ana: I never touch
a computer before.
You know, for me, that was amazing
to see how the computer work.
And my children, they were so happy.
Even my husband-- in reality,
there was a big party at home,
and from that day,
Juan started changing.
>>Juan: I was more of
a mediocre student,
a little bit apathetic
towards my studies.
But once the computer was implemented
in the curriculum and in my house,
I discovered that, you know this
is a tool for me to use in order
to get me interested into my
studies, and I did just that.
>>Narrator: Today, Mrs. Calles
is enrolled in a BA program
at Montclair University,
while Juan is a senior
at the New Jersey Institute
of Technology.
>>Juan: Last year, I worked at IBM
and I worked in the VLSI department,
the very large scale
integration department.
And I would like to think that
the curriculum at Union CD served
as a catalyst for me to
make the decision to go
into the field of technology.
>>Teacher: Ah, neat, it seems like
something right off of a web page.
>>Narrator: At the
end of their visit,
the teachers from Chicago
got a chance to see the kind
of work Union City High
School students produce.
>>Teacher: Now you also set
up the speed that it's moving.
>>Teacher: The timing
that it's refreshing.
>>Student: The timing, yeah, yeah.
>>Teacher: This is great.
>>Narrator: And the experience
confirmed their impressions
about this extraordinary district.
>>Teacher: And you
came up with these?
>>Student: From what I
discussed in my English class
and what I can write with my--
>>Student: I can say that when I came
as a freshman, I was all shy and,
you know, I guess that
was my personality.
But once you become a part of
something, and then, you know,
you're trusted with a project or
something, then you start to open up,
and then all of a sudden,
you blossom,
and then you could be a team leader.
And that's what's good
about all these programs.
>>Kareem: I want to take back
their enthusiasm for learning.
I've asked many of the
students, how do they feel
when they come to school?
When they're away from school, how
do they feel about the projects
or the assignments that
they're working on?
And they feel wonderful about it.
They have a very positive attitude
towards it, and these children feel
that this is something that's very
much a part of their character,
and this has been instilled in them
at a very early age,
in elementary schools.
And they really believe in
what they're being taught,
and the freedoms that
they've been given,
and I applaud that tremendously,
and I feel very proud of them.
>>Student: I know something
about it, 'cause I went there
and I saw how they treat everything,
but I think I need some more--
a little bit more to learn.
>>Teacher: It's great,
I'm impressed, man.
This is really nice.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.